quand vous venez ici pour la première
fois vous aviez dit à patrick bruel
qu'il était un petit peu pour vous le
portrait de l'homme idéal et depuis me
parle de vous mais ce sont avant je sais
tout s'est jamais rue ses ventes et
médias du monde quitte à pécho un bail
et moi ça me thomas et donc tu es si
gentil alors vous dites le mieux avec
les mecs ça serait un bail de deux ans
renouvelable c'est pas mal non vie
les mecs ont peur de vous draguez non je
suis sur moi si vous êtes grande
mesurait un mètre 77
bon c'est vrai que j'ai pas tellement de
poitrine mais bon ça fait rien mais les
mecs ont peur de vous draguez non c'est
vrai qu'ils ont peur mais c'est que je
suis un peu froid elle qu'un fille dans
lequel un garçon qui ne pensez surtout
qu'à peindre quelque part elle est
régulièrement bien le problème laurent
c'est quoi c'est qu'elle a un oeil
tatoué dans le dos comme c'est ça c'est
patrick qui me l'a dit
il a dit que je le sais c'est tout bien
sûr personne de l'allier jeu c'est tout
moi vous savez que c'est tout c'est pas
parce que
laurent ya toujours plus bas fils
derrière moi qu'en fin d'année
noémie lenoir si vous ne répondez pas
une question c'est yvan attal qui répond
c'est le principe du joker merci moi je
ne suis pas non plus est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vous convertir à
l'islam je passe ma vie ça va être dur
la surfer parents la super suite va pas
convertir à l'islam bien dormi le noir
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
les seins
et les vendeurs d'un sinistre non non
non non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous mettre aux
drogues dures
ah non je ne voulais pas vraiment alors
3 pac-3 me dire j accepterai jamais ça à
la maison d'accord à la maison est-ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à faire
cinq enfants
oui en même temps pour faire une famille
de foot
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg oui pourquoi pas à la
question clotilde courau que les
habitués de cette émission connaissent
bien est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre amoureux
alors alors
et comme les jeux aux etats unis quand
ils doivent les chiens et non aux états
unis et des émissions où il gagne
environ dix mille francs et doivent
aller chez des rambardes comme danger d
extrêmement vigilant tant que ce héros
division bon marché bateau
travailler c'est ma jun wang lin qui m'a
prêté jean pierre coffe 1
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qui les deux maîtresses n'ont pas si
vous voulez mais vous aviez alors un
échange change
j'oublie un des hits et si ça le rend
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse et main
qui les mettrait à quelqu'un d'autre
mais pas moi en tout cas qu'il est une
maîtresse avec sa femme voilà pas moi en
tout cas d'accord dont vous seriez pas
d'accord pour vivre à trois avec la
maîtresse même pas la peine que je vous
pose des questions n'ont ni à 4 c'est la
question la plus importante est ce que
par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle est un
c'était attendu mais milan fin mai
mais
mais il n'y avait ici le réseau social
odile méline tu serais prêt car amour à
devenir son esclave sexuelle en même
temps ciel travaillent sur cette
émission c'est un petit peu obligé alors
mais alors il en est par amour seriez
prêt à devenir son esclave sexuelle sans
problème sans problème problème c'est un
homme avant pour une femme c'est plus
dur d'être esclave sexuel quand même
c'est pas pareil c'est sympa et staff
sexuelles non mais il ya plein de trucs
qu'elle n'a pas envie de faire
ah c'est vrai